Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my complete breakdown in
hidden Marvel phase 4 Connections video
for the marvel infinity saga of movies
starting with Iron Man 1 what better way
to spend the quarantine period than
re-watching the MCU movies looking for
all the hidden clues and connections to
avengers endgame in the upcoming Marvel
phase 4 movies that we missed the first
time we saw these I'm doing two special
Infinity Saga box set giveaways for all
those blu-rays as part of this all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and I'll be picking from the best
comments I'll also add details about
this in the video description careful
for spoilers for all the Marvel movies
so far all number of these different
details and Easter eggs just to keep
track as we go along the first Iron Man
movie is probably the most important
Marvel movie ever because it's literally
the bedrock of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the present-day incarnation of
the MCU Kevin Feige literally said that
they took out a bank loan to make their
first couple of films including
Incredible Hulk but if this first Iron
Man pick didn't make enough money they
wouldn't been able to pay back their
loan to the bank and they wouldn't have
been able to make any more Marvel movies
so it was so important that Iron Man
work out Kevin Feige said he also had to
fight for Robert Downey jr. as the Iron
Man character because at the time in his
career he was viewed as a risk to
traditional studio people but look
what's happened since then in the last
10 years Kevin Feige now calls Iron Man
the heart of The Avengers which is
obviously a clever wink at his arc
reactor which Pepper Potts gave back to
him later in the movie as quote-unquote
proof Tony Stark really does have a
heart later seen during Avengers endgame
at his funeral and when the Avengers are
assembling on the time-travel platform
raising their fists to form the same
pattern as his original arc reactor the
opening scene of the movie is Iron Man
being driven to their test site while
they're listening to a CD C's back in
black ac/dc kind of became his signature
music throughout the Iron Man movies and
because so much of Iron Man influences
Tom hones spider-man character they
brought that song back during spider-man
far from home when spider-man is making
his new suit mimicking Iron Man's
movements when Iron Man was making the
mark 3 suit
probably one of the best callbacks
during spider-man far from home even if
he doesn't know who a CDC is the biggest
change that they made to Iron Man's
origin story was making it contemporary
a lot of the movie referenced the war in
Iraq and Afghanistan in the early 2000s
and this version of Tony Stark Iron Man
led a version of Stark Industries that
developed weapons for the highest bidder
a job that put him in the same social
circles as Ulysses Klaw as he said
during Avengers age of Ultron Tony Stark
used to say that to me this it's still a
great Marvel movie today it still holds
up one of the only things that dates it
though is the myspace reference in the
car right at the beginning myspace was
still a thing when this movie was being
made and Facebook was still taking off
they brought that social media joke back
around though during Avengers end game
at the beginning when Ironman is
recording that message thinking he's
about to die telling Pepper Potts please
don't post this on social media he
starts out saying that piece is bad for
business as he's trying to sell all
these weapons the most selfish he could
have possibly been by avengers endgame
in the culmination of his arc he makes
the ultimate sacrifice to save the
universe by snapping his nano infinity
gun to erase Stannis and his army so he
starts out making and selling weapons
but then slowly through the course of
the first Iron Man movie and through the
rest of his movies he winds up
destroying a lot of weapons to get rid
of them when he's captured by the
terrorists in the scene you immediately
noticed the symbol of the ten rings
behind him a reference to the Mandarin
from the Iron Man comics were finally
going to see the real Mandarin of the
MCU during Marvel phase 4 in shang-chi
in the legend of the ten rings in this
movie the ten rings are just a clever
reference to the cell based structure of
their terrorist organization at the time
it was Marvel's way of playing it safe
with the character they didn't think
they could pull off in an actual movie
but they brought the ten rings
organization back several times through
the future Iron Man movies and then
during the ant-man movie
it wasn't until Iron Man 3 that they
actually tried to do a version of the
Mandarin who obviously turned out to be
a front for Aldrich killing in an aim
aldrich killian claimed he was just
playing on legends and myths to scare
people but fans were so upset with what
they did with the Mandarin character
fake out that Marvel produced a one-shot
short
all held the king during which they
revealed there actually was a real
Mandarin and he was very very pissed
about what aim and Trevor had done with
his name
that's the Mandarin that we're going to
meet during shang-chi in the legend of
the ten rings
and while the ten rings up to this point
in the MCU has just been an organization
full of people Shang Chi and the legend
of the ten rings will also introduce the
comic book alien ten rings that the
Mandarin wears we meet Rhodey played by
Terrence Howard Iron Man's longtime
comic-book friend and Ally the reason
Howard was replaced by Don Cheadle when
we got to Iron Man 2 is just because of
a contract dispute that he got into
Marvel with the song playing in the
background when he's trying to introduce
Tony is actually a new version of the
Iron Man theme song from the classic
1960s Iron Man cartoon it becomes a
running gag during the movie and we find
out that Iron Man even hacked Rhodey
phone later to make the song his
ringtone when he was revealing himself
as the man in the suit while they were
trying to shoot him down we meet Obadiah
Stane played wonderfully by Jeff Bridges
the dude abides his arc is a lot like
Salieri with Mozart being jealous of his
genius and accomplishments later in the
movie when he brings Ironman the pizza
he starts playing one of the real-life
piano pieces written by Salieri on
Tony's piano we meet happy Hogan who's
played by the director of Iron Man 1 and
2 Jon Favreau even though his role was
relatively minor in these first couple
of Iron Man movies once Favreau passed
on directing duties to other directors
he got way more screentime as happy
Hogan during Iron Man 3 spider-man
homecoming spider-man far from home and
he will be back again during spider-man
are you dating yes what next up they
introduced Christine Everhart the
reporter who shows up a couple more
times as a foil for Pepper Potts
throughout the Marvel movies within the
context of the MCU she works for the
news organization Wagh they did some
viral teasers for Captain America Civil
War bringing her back while she was
interviewing some of the other Avengers
characters in the comics she was a
reporter for The Daily Bugle which we
recently learned in the MCU has become a
website instead of a traditional print
publication she hears Jarvis voiced by
Paul Bettany for the first time Jarvis
was an actual Butler to his father
Howard Stark the actor who played Jarvis
is one of the few people
in the MCU to debut on a TV show then
cross over into the Marvel movies
because he debuted on the agent Carter
TV series Tony grew up with a real
Jarvis is a little kid when he passed
away and Tony got older he named his AI
Jarvis as a way to honor him he then
went on to become half of the vision in
combination with Ultron's programming
Pepper Potts reminds Tony that he's
supposed to speak at his alma mater MIT
which he decides to blow off because
he's still a little bit selfish at this
point in the movie until later in
Captain America Civil War when he's been
through all the events of the first
Avengers movie all the trauma of
Avengers age of Ultron he speaks there
freely and establishes a multi-million
dollar Education Fund to benefit the
students and we'll talk about this later
but that obviously connects now to
Spider Man far from home through
Mysterio's character he's tinkering with
his hotrod car here which is a bit of a
classic throwback to the same era from
the classic Iron Man comics and it
becomes the inspiration for his new
trademark colors of red and gold when he
creates the Iron Man mark 3 armor his
trademark workshop were they filmed all
these scenes for Iron Man one was in the
old Howard Hughes aircraft hangar where
he built the Spruce Goose plane this is
especially meaningful because Stan Lee
in real life said that he took
inspiration from Howard Hughes when he
was creating the Iron Man character in
the comics we see the dummy robot for
the first time that he created it shows
up during all the Iron Man movies they
brought it back during spider-man
homecoming in the Avengers tower when
happy was packing everything up to head
to the New Avengers base they also
brought the robot back during Avengers
endgame as another callback to the first
Iron Man film in the flashbacks when
they board the plane
there's a Ghostface Killah music video
playing on the screen behind them when
the poll comes out
Ghostface Killah is a huge Iron Man
comic book fan he was supposed to have a
cameo scene in the movie they even
filmed it but it wound up on the cutting
room floor when he wakes up in the cave
Yinsen tells him that they met once at a
tech conference in Bern that was later
paid off in the Iron Man 3 opening scene
in the flash back to the 90s Yensen was
a part of Iron Man's original comic book
story but that was when his origin story
was taking place during the Vietnam War
not during the war in Iraq and
Afghanistan we meet the leader of the
ten rings Raza
he is a comic book character but he's
very different he's a bit of a cyborg
they put some goggles on him later in
the burns on his face to make him look a
little bit more like his comic book self
but when Tony catches him villain
monologuing he talks about conquering
the Far East he starts playing with his
special ring it's another subtle
reference to the comic book Mandarin in
his 10 rings of power but this ring that
Raza is wearing is not one of the actual
ten rings of power
Iron Man starts tearing down his weapons
of war to create his first arc reactor
in the Ironman Marth one suit it's
another metaphor for the path of his
character like I said not wanting to
profit from war anymore and trying to
get rid of weapons of war Marvel has
used this iconic sound of him banging
his hammer in their different movie
trailers all over the promos for all the
Avengers movies and even non Avengers
movies they even brought it back at the
end of Avengers end game playing it
after the credits as a way to bookend
the Infinity Saga of movies they open
with him banging they end with him
banging the actual Iron Man theme that
synced up with his hammer banging was
composed by Ramin Djawadi who most of
you know is the person who did the theme
music for Game of Thrones he also does a
lot of other HBO series and big movies
him being stuck in the cave is an
allegory for Joseph Campbell's hero's
journey in the trial of the innermost
cape the time in a hero's journey when
they're given their greatest challenge
and only when they overcome that
challenge can they exit the cave and
continue on their path there's a bit of
a celebrity cameo when Ironman starts
his run out the cave tearing through all
the terrorists this is Tom Morello from
Rage Against the Machine Ironman Dodgers
a missile from Raza that he later also
executes when he's saving the villagers
in the Ironman mark 3 suit dodging
another missile then there's the iconic
Burger King scene which is a big deal
for several reasons in the movie it's a
little product integration and meant to
be a funny moment to deflate some of the
tension of him just having escaped a
near-death experience then later they
referenced the scene at Iron Man's
funeral when his daughter Morgan Stark
asked happy for a cheeseburger and he
remembers the original moment saying
your dad loved cheeseburgers too oh my
gosh I love cheeseburgers you want but
going one more inception layer deeper
when they filmed this original Burger
King scene it was actually referencing a
very personal real-life moment Robert
Downey jr. had in the early 2000s when
he was still having a lot of drug
problems
he said that one day he was sitting in
his car in Los Angeles with a bunch of
drugs in a Burger King burger and it was
all just so gross that it made him
completely rethink his life and how he'd
arrived at this moment he went and
dumped all his drugs in the ocean which
they later reference during Ironman 3
when he dumps his arc reactor in the
ocean a nice metaphor about the path his
life has taken in real life and in the
movies but then we meet Coulson for the
first time and we get our first big
shield reference the shield acronym
strategic homeland intervention
enforcement and logistics division they
make a joke about the title being really
hard to pronounce
Coulson makes a couple different name
jokes which are references to the
original meaning of the shield acronym
which has changed a couple times in the
comics it used to be supreme
headquarters international espionage Law
Enforcement Division also a bit of a
mouthful Iron Man pisses off Obadiah
Stane when he announces stark tech won't
be making weapons anymore Obadiah Stane
references his comic book name Iron
Monger
then we move on to Pepper Potts helping
Ironman remove his first arc reactor and
switching to the new one saves it later
gives it back to him as a gift proof the
Tony Stark has a heart as I said they
bring it back around when Ironman uses
it to save his life after Obadiah Stane
steals the new arc reactor and then
again during his funeral during Avengers
endgame just tying things back to the
beginning it's a great visual metaphor
for his arrow arc across the Infinity
saga of movies and becoming the
metaphorical heart of The Avengers when
he's making the Iron Man mark 3 armor
and Jarvis almost paints it all gold
that's a reference to the golden variant
mark 1 armor from the classic comics
Stan Lee has a funny cameo scene with
Iron Man mistaking him as Hugh Hefner at
the party he was playing himself he was
playing Stan Lee in the movie there was
even a deleted scene later when Ironman
realizes that Stan Lee and apologizes
Stan Lee says don't worry this happens
all the time I get mistaken for Hugh
Hefner a lot when Ironman learns about
the crisis in the Middle Eastern town
wants to help out he finds out that it's
actually yen's ins hometown Gomorrah
that he told him about in the cave when
those Jets are chasing him they make a
couple of whiplash references about the
comic book villain who would eventually
go on to be the villain of Iron Man 2
Ivan Vanko aka whiplash the pilots call
out the name whiplash on the comms then
later Iron Man is making fun of Rhodey
the other men he says he hooked up with
a dude named Ivan while this is all
happening Obadiah Stane is in his house
getting pissed off watching the news you
see a chessboard in the background
that's actually a clever reference to
the villain group he created in the
comics called the chess men when iron
man comes back to his lab you see the
prototype Captain America shield for the
first time laying on the table when
Pepper Potts goes to steal the files off
of Stan's computer one of the files
actually says Lebowski
because Jeff Bridges is the dude they
also reference Lebowski during avengers
endgame when iron man shouts to thor to
get out of the way we get that famous
scene of stayin yelling at william
Ginter Reva for not being a smartest
Tony Stark which would later inspire him
to join forces with Mysterio another
disgruntled stark Tech employee and try
to steal his orbital weapons platform
technology he also steals all of
Mysterio's files and Technology at the
end of that movie so they're still
technically could be a Mysterio in
future movies as part of a sinister six
team he's played by Peter Billingsley
who in real life most people know is the
little kid Ralphie from Christmas story
he's a longtime friend of John Favreau
so that's why he showed up during the
Iron Man movies when Obadiah Stane goes
to steal Tony Stark's arc reactor he
paralyzes him briefly which Iron Man
later borrowed the technique when he was
trying to steal the Infinity Gauntlet
off thanos using mantas to temporarily
paralyze him we start to get a whole
bunch of rocks and easter eggs during
the big final fight against Iron Monger
you notice in the background there's a
Roxxon building Roxxon shows up all over
the MCU movies and TV shows
agent Carter Iron Man 3 Thor
cloak-and-dagger daredevil Netflix then
the movies subverts the long-standing
trope of the superhero identity when
Iron Man just cast the doors wide open
revealing himself I am Iron Man one of
the most iconic lines in a movie in the
last 15 years Kevin Feige himself
revealed that it wasn't in the original
script it was an improv from Robert
Downey jr. on the day they filmed it
they then brought the line back in his
final defeat of Thanos when he snapped
his nano Infinity Gauntlet a perfect
line to go out on
we get our very iconic post-credit scene
with Nick Fury coming to tell Iron Man
about the Avengers and set that movie up
but in an alternate deleted version of
this scene he also references the x-men
spider-man in The Hulk because at the
time Kevin Feige had always hoped that
they'd be able to cross over all those
characters with the Avengers movies
Kevin Feige himself having worked on the
original Bryan Singer x-men movie at Fox
but my next breakdown in Easter eggs
video is going to be four Incredible
Hulk because we're going in release
order that video will post in the next
couple of days make sure you have alerts
on for my channel so you don't miss that
video everyone let me know in the
comments have you spotted any big Easter
eggs and Marvel phase four connections
during the first Iron Man movie that I
didn't mention in the video and click
here to learn about all the big things
in Thor for love and thunder the Taika
waitit just teased and click here for my
brand new spider-man into the spider
verse 2 teaser trailer in Easter eggs
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe I'll see you guys
tonight!